me he dado cuenta de que cuando los
estudiantes tienen que resolver
problemas de atención se les dificulta
más que cualquier otro problema que
involucre fuerzas y vamos a hablar de
por qué en un minuto
veremos algunos ejemplos que involucran
la atención para tratar de desmitificar
esta fuerza y hacer que nos sintamos más
cómodos encontrando la y así no nos
molestaremos tanto cuando nos toque
resolver este tipo de problemas y
también vamos a hablar de las ideas
erróneas que muchas personas tienen en
relación con esta fuerza de tensión y de
esta manera ustedes no cometerán estos
errores para dejar esto más claro vamos
a definir qué es tensión la atención es
una fuerza que es ejercida mediante una
cuerda o un cable un alambre o cualquier
elemento que parezca una cuerda aquí
tenemos una cajita de botanas de queso y
le atamos una cuerda a esta y vamos a
calcular con cuánta fuerza tenemos que
jalar la y ya que la fuerza es
transmitida mediante una cuerda le vamos
a llamar tensión
esta es una fuerza como cualquier otra y
la voy a llamar t 1 porque voy a usar
otras fuerzas de tensión aquí pues
agregaremos más cuerdas la atención es
como cualquier otra fuerza y así la
debemos de tratar sencillamente es una
fuerza que resulta ser transmitida
mediante una cuerda que va a suceder en
esta cuerda pues las cuerdas normalmente
están compuestas de fibras que están
entretejidas están unidas entre ellas de
manera que cuando ejerce una fuerza en
este lado y comienzo a jalar este lado
de la cuerda esta fuerza va a comenzar a
transmitirse a través de todas las
fibras hasta llegar a este otro lado y
ejerce una fuerza sobre esta caja lo que
sucede es que las fibras de este lado
pues están entretejidas y conforme vayan
jalando de estas fibras éstas a su vez
van a jalar las otras fibras que tienen
junto las cuales a su vez van a jalar
las fibras que tienen junto a ellas y
así sucesivamente y esa es la idea
una vez que aquí estoy ejerciendo
fuerza esta va a jalar a las fibras de
juntos o va a transmitirse a las fibras
de juntos todo esto se repite hasta que
eventualmente llegamos a este otro
extremo de la cuerda de manera que si en
ese extremo estuve jalando con una
fuerza en este otro extremo también voy
a estar jalando con esa fuerza la
atención es útil y por lo tanto las
cuerdas también ya que nos permiten
ejercer una fuerza a distancia y es a
una distancia tan larga como sea nuestra
cuerda y ustedes podrán encontrarse que
en un problema típico de tensión nos
digan que hay una fuerza de tensión
actuando sobre esta caja que cause que
esta caja comience a acelerarse con una
aceleración a cero y la pregunta puede
decir cuánta atención es necesaria para
acelerar esta caja de masa m con esta
aceleración a cero y bueno muchos
problemas nos van a decir supongan que
la cuerda no tiene masa y ustedes se
pueden quedar
como que la cuerda no tiene masa primero
como podríamos tener una cuerda sin masa
y segunda para que nos serviría una
cuerda que no tiene masa la razón por la
que los problemas de física establece en
esta suposición es porque si ustedes se
imaginan una cuerda que tiene masa iu a
lo mejor es una cuerda pesada muy masiva
bastante gruesa pues entonces estas
fibras de acá en este extremo no sólo
van a tener que estar jalando la caja
también van a tener que jalar toda la
cuerda que se encuentra entre la caja y
el extremo así que van a tener que jalar
esta cuerda pesada que se encuentra
entre ellos mientras que estas fibras
que están aquí pues solo van a tener que
jalar la caja y este pedazo de cuerda
que hay aquí la mitad de ésta que es
pesada pero no tan pesada como la cuerda
completa y además la caja así que la
atención aquí va a ser un poquito menor
y la tensión en este otro extremo pues
estas cuerdas sólo van a estar jalando a
la caja no van a estar jalando más
cuerda ya están en el extremo por lo que
la atención en este extremo va a ser
mucho más pequeña que las que se
encuentra aquí de manera que tendremos
un gradiente de tensión o una variación
de tensión en la cuerda vamos a tener
una atención más grande en este extremo
y va a ir disminuyendo poco a poco hasta
llegar a este otro extremo y esto es
complicado realmente no queremos
meternos en este tipo de cálculos y es
por eso que los problemas de física se
establece que la cuerda no tiene masa
para no meternos en estos cálculos
complicados pero realmente sabemos que
la quadra tiene que estar hecha de algún
material no es que no tenga masa
simplemente queremos dar a entender que
para el problema la masa de la cuerda no
la consideramos la podemos ignorar ya
que es una masa muy pequeña en
comparación de todo lo demás que tenemos
en el problema aun cuando existe una
pequeña variación de la atención que se
encuentra en la cuerda realmente no no
va a afectar nuestro cálculo a lo mejor
la atención en este extremo es de 15
newtons y la atención en este otro
extremo es de 14.999 newtons así que hay
una pequeña diferencia de atención pero
es insignificante bueno vamos a tratar
de resolver este problema quitamos esto
que puse aquí arriba
y nos preguntamos cuál es la atención
que necesitamos aquí para poder jalar
esta caja con una aceleración a cero
para resolver estos problemas vamos a
dibujar un diagrama de fuerzas como lo
haríamos en cualquier otro caso de
diagrama de fuerzas dibujamos las
fuerzas que actúan en cierto objeto
tenemos la fuerza de gravedad
que es igual a m por g y la fuerza de
gravedad es maravillosa tiene su propia
fórmula sustituyó los valores aquí y ya
tengo la fuerza de gravedad y si estamos
en la tierra la fuerza de gravedad
siempre nos va a jalar hacia abajo y
como tenemos esta caja en contacto con
el suelo vamos a tener una fuerza normal
ya que el suelo es una superficie la
caja tiene una superficie y dos
superficies en contacto van a tener una
fuerza normal y además vamos a tener esa
tensión y aquí tenemos nuestra primera
idea errónea muchas veces las personas a
ver esta línea piensen que estoy
empujando la caja con la cuerda lo cual
no tiene ningún sentido no podemos
empujar con una cuerda y si no me creen
pausa en el vídeo tomen una cuerda aten
la algún objeto y traten de empujar ese
objeto con la cuerda y verán que no se
puede realmente la cuerda va a quedar
muy suave no nos va a permitir empujar
algo sin embargo si podemos jalar cosas
con la cuerda la cuerda causa esta
tensión que es una fuerza que está
jalando ya que al jalar con la cuerda
voy a tensar la voy a estirarla y voy a
empezar a ejercer una fuerza en la caja
la voy a empezar a mover
la fuerza normal es una fuerza que
empuja no que jala ya que la fuerza
normal es aquella que se encuentra en
dos superficies que están en contacto y
que se están empujando mutuamente el
suelo empuja la caja hacia arriba para
evitar que lo atraviese y por otra parte
la atención es una fuerza que jala así
que esta fuerza t1 en mi diagrama de
fuerzas la tengo que dibujar con esta
dirección esto este uno estas son todas
mis fuerzas aunque podría tener fricción
aquí pero digamos que esta fábrica de
votadas de queso es muy eficiente y
tiene superficie sin fricción para poder
transportar sus cajas de botanas de
queso lo más rápido posible y quizá
suene un poco increíble esto de la
superficie sin fricción no sé a lo mejor
tienen algunas rueditas aquí para evitar
la fricción pero por el momento vamos a
mantener simple y sencillo este problema
ya más adelante lo iremos complicando
ahora como calcula la atención la razón
por la que yo creo que las personas no
les gusta resolver estos problemas de
tensión es porque la atención no tiene
una fórmula bonita como la de la
gravedad véanla acá la fuerza de
gravedad solamente es m por g y podemos
calcularla inmediatamente pero para la
fuerza de tensión no hay una fórmula
directa que podamos poner de t es igual
a esto la forma en la que encontramos la
atención en casi todos los problemas es
usando la segunda ley de newton la
segunda ley de newton nos dice que la
aceleración es igual a la fuerza neta
sobre la masa y si a ustedes no les
gusta la segunda ley de newton
probablemente tampoco les va a gustar
encontrar la atención lo que tenemos que
usar para encontrarla bueno cuál va a
ser la aceleración primero tengo que
encontrar la dirección hacia dónde va a
ir esta pues voy a elegir la dirección
horizontal ya que mi tensión que quiero
encontrar se encuentra en esta dirección
horizontal
mi aceleración en esta dirección
horizontal es a 0 que va a ser igual a
mi fuerza neta y en la dirección x sólo
tengo una fuerza que es mi fuerza de
tensión pongo aquí t 1 y pues voy a
considerar que la dirección hacia la
derecha es positiva por lo que aquí le
pongo más de 1 escribo el + o el
positivo aquí para hacer evidente que la
dirección hacia la derecha es positiva
aunque si quisiéramos podríamos poner
que la dirección izquierda es la
positiva pero sería un poquito extraño
en este caso esto lo dividimos entre
nuestra masa y ahora puedo despejar a
tf1 hago algo de álgebra y me queda que
t 1 es igual a la masa por la
aceleración 0 la atención en esta cuerda
de aquí es la masa por la aceleración
que tiene la caja en esta dirección
así que recuerden que no debemos dibujar
la aceleración como una fuerza esto no
se hace a veces las personas tratan de
dibujarla así pero es una aberración la
aceleración no es una fuerza
la aceleración es causada o ocasionada
por una fuerza pero la aceleración en sí
misma no es una fuerza así que nunca
traten de dibujarla así y bueno aquí nos
sufrimos mucho para encontrar la
atención claro que este es uno de los
problemas más sencillos que nos podemos
encontrar y seguramente ustedes se van a
encontrar problemas que son más
complicados que éste vamos a complicar
un poquito digamos que de ese lado
alguien también está jalando la caja con
otra cuerda aquí tenemos de dos tenemos
personas que se están peleando por esta
cajita de botanas de queso y si tenemos
a alguien que está jalando de este lado
que va a pasar aquí y digamos que de
este otro lado seguimos tenido una
persona que dice ah no te vas a quedar
con mis votantes y está jalando con una
fuerza que mantiene esta aceleración va
a jalar con la fuerza necesaria para
mantener esta aceleración a pesar de que
se tiene esta otra persona que está
jalando de este otro lado
esto cambiaría a mis cálculos de acá
bueno voy a tener que modificar mi
diagrama de fuerzas pero esta fuerza de
acá no la puedo dibujar como si
estuviera empujando recuerden que no
puedo empujar con la tensión sólo puedo
jalar así que con este acuerdo estoy
jalando hacia la izquierda lo dibujamos
como t2 y como lo incluyo aquí bueno es
una fuerza hacia la izquierda por lo que
va a tener un signo negativo lo resto
porque quedamos que la dirección hacia
la izquierda va a tener siempre signo
negativo ahora hago mi álgebra
multiplico a ambos lados por m me queda
m por a pero voy a tener que sumar t 2
en ambos lados lo cual tiene sentido ya
que si voy a jalar aquí pues quiero que
mi t 1 compense esta otra fuerza que va
en sentido contrario
de manera que en mi cajita sigue
acelerándose con a 0 y como tengo gente
que está jalando de este otro lado pues
mi tensión uno tiene que aumentar para
compensar esto
digamos que la gente se está volviendo
loca por esta caja de queso y ahora
tenemos a alguien con una cuerda que
está por acá
y que le está jalando de este lado y la
está jalando con una fuerza de 3 aquí
tenemos que alguien está jalando esto
con un ángulo y digamos que esto está en
un ángulo theta y ahora esto como me va
a cambiar los cálculos ya que queremos
que esté uno sea lo suficientemente
fuerte van a seguir manteniendo esta
aceleración a cero en esta dirección
bueno aquí va a cambiar que ya tengo una
fuerza de tensión que va hacia arriba en
mi diagrama de fuerzas tenemos aquí a t
3 con un ángulo theta
y ahora no puedo poner directamente 13
en esta fórmula esta fórmula sólo me
sirve para la dirección horizontal por
lo que tengo que incluir solamente el
componente horizontal de esta fuerza t
31 que a este componente horizontal le
voy a llamar t 3x y es lo que puedo
incluir en mi fórmula tengo el
componente de 3g pero no lo voy a poner
en esa fórmula porque es una fuerza
vertical por lo que no me va a afectar
la aceleración horizontal solo me va a
afectar a aquellas fuerzas que funcionen
verticalmente bueno como voy a encontrar
de 3x pues vamos a usar la trigonometría
es lo que hacemos para encontrar los
componentes de un vector y aquí voy a
usar coseno detecta ya que conozco este
lado y t 13 x es adyacente al ángulo y
como es un lado adyacente al ángulo me
funciona usar el coseno dt está la
definición del coseno es el lado a
decente sobre la hipotenusa y mi lado
adyacente éste
3x mi hipotenusa es este lado de aquí
que es toda mi fuerza t 3 si esta
atención no fuera de 50 newtons con un
ángulo de 30 grados no podría poner los
50 newtons aquí directamente tendrían
que ser 50 minutos por y aquí tengo que
despejar por t 3x de 3x es igual
multiplico ambos lados por 3 que serían
nuestros 50 newtons la magnitud completa
de mi tensión x el coste no detecta si
fuera un ángulo de 30 grados
aquí pondría mis 30 grados y esto es lo
que pondría en esta fórmula de acá lo
que incluiría en mi segunda ley de
newton no puedo poner la fuerza completa
porque esta fuerza completa no está
actuando totalmente en la dirección
horizontal la fuerza total está
compuesta de su componente horizontal y
su componente vertical y el componente
vertical no me afecta esta fórmula de
aquí no me afecta la aceleración
horizontal sólo el componente horizontal
de esa atención es lo que me afecta la
aceleración esto lo pongo aquí y lo sumo
ya que este componente está actuando
hacia el lado derecho de la dirección
horizontal y todo lo que va hacia la
derecha lo estoy poniendo con signo
positivo así que aquí pongo más de 3
coseno de teta y nuevamente encuentro t
1 multiplicando ambos lados por m tengo
m por acero sumo t 2 en ambos lados y en
ambos lados resto t 3 coseno de teta
y de esta manera ya tengo mi de 1
calculada algebraica mente y eso tiene
sentido ya que mi tensión t 1 ya no
tiene que ser tan grande porque tiene
una fuerza que le está ayudando a jalar
en esta dirección hay alguien que está
de su lado que también está jalando
hacia la derecha no tienen que estar
jalando con tanta fuerza y esto se ve
reflejado aquí en esta recta de 1 se va
a decrementar si le damos una fuerza que
lo esté ayudando en esta dirección
así que conceptualmente esto es como
nuestra fuerza que uno puede aumentar o
disminuir y es así como lo debemos
trabajar con las fuerzas involucradas
podemos seguir agregando fuerzas aquí
incluso la fricción si es que tuviéramos
una fuerza de fricción hacia la
izquierda
tendríamos solamente que incluirlo como
una fuerza aquí y tenemos que seguir
usando la segunda ley de newton y
despejar algebraica mente la atención
que nos interesa así que como repaso
recuerden que la forma de encontrar la
atención eso
la segunda ley de newton hay que fijarse
en usar los signos de manera correcta y
también en hacer correctamente nuestros
cálculos algebraicos para poder despejar
la atención que nos interesa y también
recuerden que la fuerza de tensión no es
una fuerza que empuje es solamente una
fuerza que jala podemos jalar con una
cuerda pero nunca podemos empujar con
una cuerda y en este problema la
atención a través de la cuerda fue la
misma ya que supusimos que nuestra
cuerda no tiene masa o que la masa de la
cuerda es tan insignificante en
comparación con la masa de nuestra caja
que podemos ignorarla en otras palabras
la atención en cualquier punto de esta
cuerda es la misma y esto pudo haberlos
hecho la diferencia si la pregunta fuera
que tanta fuerza tendría que ejercer la
persona que estuviera de este lado
jalando esta cuerda para generar esta
aceleración si la cuerda en sí misma
fuera masiva en este caso la persona no
solo tendría que estar jalando
para mover la caja sino también para
mover la cuerda masiva y tendríamos una
variación en la atención aquí y
realmente ya sería bastante complicado
este cálculo por lo que si suponemos que
la masa de la cuerda es insignificante
podremos encontrar que la fuerza que
necesita esta persona para jalar la caja
se va a transmitir como tensión en la
cuerda y va a llegar sin diluir a la
caja si esta persona aquí jala con 50
newtons este punto de la cuerda también
va a jalar a la caja con 50 newtons